t'es cool
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire la vérité c'est que je suis
censé être en prison pour quel
truc de super-héros quel super-héros es-tu
pacificateur sors d'ici il n'y a pas de
super-héros appelé mec pacificateur je suis
célèbre
[Musique]
tu es un tueur né avec expertise  dans
chaque arme sous l'humanité,
je vous donne la chance de rester en dehors de la
prison et de travailler pour moi tuer des gens méchants
c'est hardcore
vous gérez le domaine john économiste
technologie et tactique
et c'est notre nouvelle recrue qu'ils
vous cautionnent don  pas besoin de tirer sur les gens après elle
pour les tuer,
qui est le gars qui regarde derrière
la poubelle le justicier essaie d'être
utile
notre première cible est le sénateur roiland golf le
golf voyage peut-être avec sa famille
êtes-vous sûr que ces deux enfants sont sortis de
ces parents qui forment un
couple attrayant et dont l'un a l'air d'être
sorti d'eux mais l'autre a l'air bien
pour un bébé un bébé de fesses ouais mon frère
aîné m'a dit qu'il y a deux types de
bébés un qui sort normal  et
puis le pire des bébés dans tous les sens, ils
sortent des fesses d'une femme
oh je croyais que j'étais un bébé jusqu'à l'âge de
14 ans. cela explique beaucoup de choses
il y a quelque chose en lui qui est
triste
hé papa
ça ne me dérangeait pas  un nancy
boy comme tu le
sais ces derniers temps je suis juste comme un maniaque hé
non non c'est parce que nous sommes des tueurs nés
ce qui nous sépare des autres tueurs est que
nous ne tuons que les mauvaises personnes
généralement à
moins qu'il y ait une erreur que
vous utilisez être un imbécile est un moyen de  repoussez les
gens,
vous êtes nul sur powerpoint, mais si vous
laissez tomber que les
gens pourraient
vraiment vous aimer vraiment
papa
[Applaudissements]
toi